為什麼一直說南亞科世界強
因為他在創立史新高
但是其他的世界大廠都沒有
到底新高還有一點距離
到底我們的科立廠厲害在哪裡
但也不能只有南亞科
這邊要來請教現榮
華邦電雷 立即電雷
其他漢人雷
通通都有串貢
記憶體科立廠到底要不要全部跟上
今天要教我們
到底你是怎麼抓大戶的
大戶連續兩個三周
都在買電力股
好 那第一個
還先來看一下記憶體
這兩天最重要的大事就是
海利市 砸了四十兆寒元
四十兆寒元是多少
大概換算台幣九千兩百億
美金是兩百八十八億
那這個金額大家發現到
大概就是海利市跑去美國發ADR
他用增資薪股的方式
募集了兩百六十五億的現金
結果這兩百六十五億
大家發現你募集了私金之後
這地方把股權稀釋了
所以原始股東不爽
現在兩百六十幾億的資金
全部又買庫產股
然後買了2400萬股就把它注消掉
等於說海利市這個ADR
本來西式股權的效應
大概這個部分就被他抵消掉
所以看到今天三星的股價
漲了9.4%
重點是海利市大漲了12.7%
跟這個買庫場股
有比較大的一個關係在的
不錯
我覺得他們現在對於股市的想法
有在進步
要不然我們都覺得
南韓不會做股票
對 現在這地方
他開始有改進 之前發現
增資大家這個供給增加
現在是把供給撿掉
這地方股票減少了股價就漲上去了
那當然還有一個關鍵
就是川普政府現在施壓蘋果
不要去買中國的記憶體
那這個部分其實也跟現在整個記憶體
多空搭輪站
他看空的都覺得說
第一個這地方第二季財報大賺的時候
景氣是不是達到高峰
所以獲利數字公佈出來
很多人看到股價都是開高走低
反手賣出
另外一個基本面大家最擔心的就是
韓國跟中國都在大幅度擴充產能
尤其中國擴產的速度非常的快
認為說未來供給會大幅度增加
但是如果說中國擴充的產能
現在這個地方川普不准
蘋果去買
不准在這地方歸達去買
等於說進不了美國為主的國際市場的話
就算新產能開出來
對全球的記憶體的供給增加
這個部分影響就會降到最低
那在這個地方
我這個看法
目前記憶體多空大論戰
看空的剛才講了
第二季的獲利大賺
會不會是代表景氣達到高峰
以及未來的供給會大幅度增加
那供給的部分剛才提到
中國的新產能
有川普幫大家擋著
進不了國際市場
影響降到最低之外
更重要的是
大家都只看到供給會增加
忽略了一件事情
就是目前AI市場
對於整個記憶體的需求
還在持續的增加
目前公幣應求的局面
其實這地方都還有
這個繼續擴大的現象
換句話說
證據在哪裡
就在記憶體的現貨報價
還在持續上漲
目前DDR5已經漲到了53美金
DDR4的部分
更是突破了90美金
數字會說話
代表說記憶體
真的報價還在上漲
公幣應求並沒有扭轉
所以第二季的獲利
會不會就是達到高峰呢
目前來看
記憶體製造這一塊
下半年這個獲利
還會持續盤高
景氣還是沒有達到高峰的現象
我認為第三季獲利
還是會繼續上去的
其實這邊有一條很有趣
標虎去調升了美光的債務評級
變成Tubal B的Pros
這個在網上一集
它又可以變成A的Miners
它以後發債的成本會降低很多
這根本就是全面來相助
所以這個部分
美光現在賺到錢
如果說未來要發債
成本又能夠降低的話
我想整個記憶體的評價
還是有機會進一步的再來做拉高
所以關鍵來了
那股價的部分呢
當然南亞科在這個地方
看到八月份以來外資
這個投信都是在地方同步繼續賣
四百張大戶連續兩周
又增持下去
所以股價的部分
現在已經這地方正如我們上次說的
很有機會再創歷史新高
所以全球記憶體股價
之前跌到歪的時候拉回
現在大盤其他記憶體股只是反彈
他已經率先創了歷史新高
那只是創新高我們常常講
他的股信的地方會發現
這個5月5號發動一波公式
過高就拉回 過高就會拉回
過高就會拉回
所以每次都不要在這個過高的時候
急著就去搶
那拉回來
我覺得這地方再來找買點
會是比較適合
所以技術面的部分
我們就觀察
8月7號這裡有一個這地方十字線
真大 那麼做股票的操作策略就是
先找支撐
支撐這地方能夠找到
拉回來支撐不破的時候
是不是就有機會繼續往上推進上去
那我覺得說南亞科的部分
這個還是記憶體的首選
上半年EPS賺了23塊
但不是最高峰
下半年我覺得還是有繼續
這個地方走高的機會
那再來看華邦電的部分
華邦電這個地方
這個股價看到說
最近又開始橫盤整理
那他比較吃虧一點就是
營收比重目前D-RAM
大概占了53%
Flash也有31%
邏輯IC則是占13%左右
最近的操作
你會看到股價在地方反彈上來
但是這裡看到7月6號的時候
股價跌下來反彈
這裡有個高點
那這次反彈上來
高點也大概都落在200塊左右的位置
所以目前股價大概還在這個位置
正當整理為主
但是低檔支撐8月5號
這個多方缺口
目前來看
熟的也都相當的穩
大概在157.5到164.5之間
這裡我覺得認為也可以熟得住
也沒有太大問題
還是有機會在這個
手足支撐之下
至少維持一個區間操作的模式
是可以的
因為我剛剛一看就說
怎麼這麼弱
然後現容就說哪有弱還好
至少站上了均線
都站上均線了
是好轉的一個形式
那當然一個族群
大家最關心的就是
這地方上游顆粒
目前來看都還是很強
甚至像金豪科有創歷史新高
那很多人關心的是
模組廠的部分 群聯 遺鼎 威剛
怎麼這個地方
這個股價最近像群聯
公佈出來上倍能EPS
187塊股價又跌了
最近這地方外資投薪的部分
還是在8月份持續的慢
那400張大戶
其實注意到開始有這地方
連兩周增持 遺鼎也有
有減轉正的現象
看他群聯的部分
最近提到這地方
200張大戶開始有低檔
慢慢的再做增持了
只是最近外資還在調節
賣最多就是公布財報
賺了187塊的一天
開高走低下來
但是形態上面會不會變成說
現在左肩出來 底部出來
這次拉回來
如果守住了半年線
這個地方做一個右肩
那這個就可以觀察一下
以左肩的位置
大概在168.5
在這個地方做一個對稱的話
拉回來這個左肩能夠守得住
接下來股價就有機會
那其實短線上
因為8月14號就是公佈財報出來
上半年賺187塊那天的黑K
這個太醜了一點
所以股價如果說
要正式的轉強
大概那天的高點要先過著去
如果過著去突破景線
我們講一個頭剪底的形態
就有機會出來
股價就有一個最起碼
開始發動攻勢的機會了
貨利真的很好
但是說實話
去年也漲到過2880
也不是沒有漲
現在感原上就是它的貨利
跟市場的籌碼跟認同度
要達到一個平衡才有辦法再攻
要不然明明獲利
其實挑不出毛病來
那關鍵如果說第三季
營收持續創高
到時候第三季獲利
會不會又比第二季來得更好
化解了大家擔心
第二季見到高峰疑慮
大概就是股價發動攻勢的時刻了
因為潘董到處跑
有點餘心不忍了
是
怎麼把人不買單呢
所以我們等
靜待一下第三季的一個狀態
對 好 那當然記憶體的部分
我們說目前還是以顆粒為主
但是模組廠也不用這個地方太過於悲觀
那這個這是上之前講
之前講7月30號講
臺灣電友創下歷史新高
最近有回檔到這個往下回檔了一下
所以這邊的話還是持續看好
把通波機板類的
感覺上都已經創高了
市場的共識蠻高的
那均線也是一個標準多頭排列
回測一下這地方這個時日線
好像今天也有收下銀線
所以目前這一組股價還是這個維持多頭的結構
只要這地方之前
這裡有一個黑K
黑K完又再度過高
通常就是洗完盤繼續再攻
這個低點不要去跌破
大概這個攻擊結構
還是會維持下去
那雙紅的部分
最近股價又拉回了
因為我們之前是在這個
剛好最低點那天
810塊跟大家介紹的
果然公布出來
你說創新高收
一波急漲了大概兩成多的幅度
那最近也稍微做個拉回
但是我們觀察到
下半年GP300我們說過
追加的訂單已經開始出現
所以營收7月份也創立史新高
第二季這個地方新舊產品的一個交換期
大概結束之後
下半年的動能會開始加速
所以我覺得股價應該沒有問題
還是有機會繼續再上到
雙紅是散熱裡面比較明顯落後的
要不要換到齊鴻
或是要不要換到最近大復活的監測
如果說想要這地方追求
快速能夠創新高的股票
齊鴻監測可能會快一點
對 型態比較強
那如果說有耐心
我們喜歡第一檔布局雙紅
我覺得還是可以繼續關注
安全 可能比較安全
就沒有大漲這樣
沒錯
那當然接下來
去觀察大戶的一個動向的部分
那大戶動向怎麼去觀察
我們常常說
這個做股票好像這個
帶兵作戰孫子兵法說
知己知彼才能擺這樣不大
那我們也是怎麼樣去知己知彼
看大盤 我們會去看
量能跟籌碼來觀察
大戶 散戶
現在在想些什麼
而且通常要反市場操作
就是量如果1.5兆 1.6兆
全市場最FORMED的時候
你反而要冷靜一點
那整到這地方
大家開始不敢買股票了
融資在大減
然後反而又是減便宜的時刻
所以大盤我們通常會建議大家
反市場操作是一個很重要的原則
那個股的部分
我們又要觀察
每個禮拜法人的動作 大戶的動作
那通常我會去觀察
400張的大戶
有沒有連續兩球增加的現象
因為如果說只看單週
比較容易碰到短線
隔日充大戶 隔週充大戶
只禮拜五買了
禮拜一就要買的狀況
所以兩個禮拜是確定一下
大戶真的有比較積極的
才做一個波端的佈局
那我們就站在巨人的肩膀上
不是說要去吃個豆腐什麼的
是用大戶的視角
來看看大戶現在在看什麼族群
說每個禮拜都是把大戶
這個400張大戶
有連續增加的股票挑出來之後
再去分類
大概哪一些是最近大戶
比較積極在進攻的一個族群
來選定未來的方向
那像最近就發現到
整個這個電力族群的部分
從上游這地方
光寶科做電源供應器的
BPU的ASKY跟新生力
到成吉很久的重電骨化
最近這地方大戶
又有這地方
連續兩週三週再增持的現象了
重電骨大戶會不會
都沒有震到癖癖啊
那這個部分我們就先來看一下
第一個當然光寶科的部分
是大概最近大家最熱門的
兩四百張大火連續增持
顧家已經在地方悄悄地創了新高
286.5
那也會發現到大戶現在
進場的時候本益比很重要
像本益比高的台達電
大戶就還在一直賣
那本益比低的光寶科反而成為重點
那顧家當然創新高
如果說不想急著追
就拉回來觀察一下
8月5號這裡有一個大量
這個所謂的洗盤
洗盤的低點
如果說能夠去疊
這個就守得住247
不要破
股價還是有機會繼續走高
那如果說
這已經創新高不想追
剛才講到重電股的部分
最近好像這地方
開始有加溫了
我們要相信大埔
因為剛剛講一個事情很重要
光寶科其實也盤很久
那本應比相對合理
還是發動了
所以現在 一動就創新高
中心電
到底看到這地方
這個最近是外資有在做加持
其實外資在買的時候
四百張大幅是連續兩週
才做一個增加
而且幅度還滿明顯的
那上半年EPS賺了四塊五
這是創歷史新高的
法人估計今年保守一點
八塊七到九塊
明年已經有人估到十二到十五塊
所以本利比算了算
這個如果說
就從今年九塊來上十八倍而已
也不貴
如果明年大幅度承擔到十二到十五塊
我覺得最近大幅應該是開始卡位
這一塊是不是這地方
當AI算力的瓶頸
開始轉移到電力瓶頸的時候
股價我覺得就是
可能有加溫上去的機會了
好 因為真的
改表態的原因是
可能用今年來看
前面到200塊這邊的時候
大家還覺得還好
可是已經到了8月下旬了
明年如果會成長
現在是台積電設備供應鏈
對啊
那現在看起來
確實就來到一個
真的叫做評價非常合理的階段了
沒錯
可能就是在等那個發動點
重電真的好久好久沒有發動了
尤其是他已經確認是接到
推煉訂單
對 所以這個部分
達入到台積電公衣店做一個加持
會不會接下來成為股價發動點
我覺得投資朋友都可以在未來度假觀察
非常謝謝憲榮
謝謝